et maintenant j'accueille corneille
et
[Musique]
corneille bonsoir nous avons avec nous
vous avez 25 ans cormeilles et vous
venez de faire une entrée remarquée dans
le r'n'b avec ça
[Musique]
or die l'album s'appelle parce qu'on
vient de loin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la totale assurer la promo il ya
tous les interdits sont alors l'album
s'appelle parce qu'on vient de loin
c'est vrai que vous venez de loi vous
venez du rwanda et votre vrai nom
cormeilles c'est cornelius nyungura
exactement j'ai bien roulé er menace à
nyon voilà mais comme tout le monde se
foutait un petit peu de votre gueule
quand vous étiez petit on vous a appelé
corneille tout simplement
alors votre père et tutsis et votre mère
et où tous exactement drama familial
citée à kigali donc que vous avez
commencé à faire de la de la musique en
écoutant boys tumen et la première compo
de corneille c'est à l'âge de 15 ans
piano est donc assez assez précoce à 16
ans vont remporter un concours
découverte de la télévision rwandaise
une espèce de graines de stars on peut
dire c'est ça voilà c'était la première
année de la télévision au rang d'un la
télévision est arrivée un peu
tardivement et nous en 93 et on avait
et on avait 16 ans puis on s'est
retrouvé troisième avec des gens qui
avait 15 ans de métier mais que c'était
encourageant et or voilà donc début de
carrière comme ça très très prometteur
et malheureusement anéanti par le
génocide le 15 avril 1994 vous êtes en
famille dans votre maison de kigali
quand les soldats font irruption quel
soldat je ne sais jusqu'aujourd'hui pas
qui étaient ces militaires
il ya plusieurs hypothèses ça peut être
des militaires de 2 à l'époque du fpr on
appeler l'armée rebelle qui aujourd'hui
la l'armée au pouvoir aujourd'hui et ça
pourrait bien être aussi l'autre camp
dont on s'est envoyé rentrer des gens un
jour dans le salon de vos parents et
vous savez toujours pas qui c'était
finalement c'est désormais on savait pas
qui était alors il vous réunissent dans
la même pièce il vous fusille à bout
portant
vous vous sauver in extremis votre peau
en plongeant derrière un divan du salon
mais vos parents vos trois frères vos
trois soeurs meurt sous les coups de ses
soldats vous retrouvez unique rescapé de
ce massacre
vous vous cachez au départ quelques
jours à kigali à 7,6 était ambigu comme
situation c'était très absurde en même
temps bon c'est ridicule on n'est pas
parmi les rares pays au monde où dans ta
carte d'identité on
on explique bien de quelle ethnie on
appartient accès c'est un truc c'est
complètement aberrant et donc le premier
critère pour y avait des barrages
dangereux de miliciens ou deux de
l'armée est le premier critère donc
c'était
ton appartenance ethnique par rapport à
ce qu'il ya dans ta carte d'identité
mais ça s'est assez vite ça les gens
avaient plus le temps de faire ce tribun
en regardant les cartes d'identité tout
ça donc après c'était selon la famille
c'était au faciès
exactement et moi j'ai plus gardés du
physique de mon père est donc tout six
exactement tout si donc c'était c'est un
peu plus difficile donc il a fallu que
je me cache évidemment un
mais ça ne m'a pas empêché de vivre le
génocide donc sur le terrain en madiran
donc vous cacher quelques jours à kigali
et puis vous mêlés au flot des réfugiés
des des centaines comme ça de milliers
de gens qui marchent sur les routes vers
le congo 150 km à l'est un petit peu
comme des automates quoi des gens qui
avaient des automates série de telles
horreurs que les marchés d'une façon
assez mécanique c'était c'est exactement
ça c'était c'était c'était automatique
c'est elle la survie voilà je pense que
c'est humain le l'instinct de survie qui
prend le dessus et on est en marche et
en marge du droit fait 150 km
alors ensuite évidemment grâce à des
amis de vos parents vous rejoignez
l'allemagne vous passez un petit peu de
temps en allemagne et ensuite vous allez
au canada vous allez à montréal et là
vous vous continuez à faire de la
musique et vous faites un groupe qui
s'appelle one une fête un morceau qui
marche très très bien qu'elle la
chapelle zukin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis sûr c'est la première fois que
vous leur en attendait depuis le canada
sur le canada oui ça fait longtemps
ça fait désordre tournée du mal à le
retrouver alors numéro un donc sur l'erp
les canadiens zouk il avec le groupe one
et là vous réalisez en fait corneille
que vous avez quelque chose à dire qui
ne peut pas passer par par un groupe ça
peut passer uniquement par votre
expression personnelle c'est-à-dire par
une carrière solo et vous fait cet album
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure qui
s'appelle parce qu'on vient de loin et
vous dites je dédie mon album aux gens
qui se sentent oubliés par le reste du
monde
c'est vrai dit vous et vous avez raison
on a beaucoup parlé du 11-septembre bien
sûr on a beaucoup plus parlé que du
génocide du rwanda qui a été le plus
gros génocide après l'holocauste après
la shoah c'est vrai justement pour
parler durant 70 gelé j'ai vécu cet
événement là de façon complètement
différemment j'ai touché au canada que
j'en amérique du nord j'avais de la
peine pour les familles qui avaient
perdu les leurs ce qui est complètement
normal m en même temps j'avais un
sentiment de dégoût
on s'est levés le 11 septembre il y
avait des bandes qui défie les
entrailles de tous les écrans avec les
différents donc la ville de new york
mais obtenez donc pour
suite à ces événements là et il ya eu
des milliers de morts au rwanda y ait
plus d'un million de morts plus d'un
million de morts donc ce qu'on compte on
est au courant et je sais ça ça m'a
amené à me poser la question est ce que
selon l'endroit où on grandit on est où
on vit est ce que la vie un être humain
vaut plus cher endroit à l'autre et gt
ça m'a beaucoup c'est un problème pour
moi c'était c'était vraiment un problème
pour moi vous êtes retourné au rwanda
depuis n'ont malheureusement pas mais
j'ai l'intention de dire aux parents
quand on vous voit tous les deux on se
prend à rêver à un avenir logitech
maison on n'aimait pas c'est vrai ça me
semble empêcher dégagnac version vie
conjugale
[Applaudissements]
alors donc on a faim on va jouer à un
jeu on va faire comme si vous étiez en
couple aj vous arbitrez alain plaisir
partie alors si vous étiez en couple qui
aurait fait le premier pas il paraît
timide mais je pense que c'est lui qui
aurait pu le premier parc en mai il
paraît qu'ils ne l'aient pas dit ok on
va dire je crois qu'on va dire que ouais
ouais ce que vous vous seriez embrassés
pour la première fois sur le tournage
passera pas normalement je vais le faire
on l'a pas fait a donné six petits très
subtil exactement c'était quand même sur
tournage avait un petit peu une
ambiguïté non non mais cette année
c'était bien celle des rêves c'est un
jeu est ce que si vous étiez en couple
vous auriez conçu le premier soir non
non non non déjà je fais marcher la main
pendant très longtemps d'accord avec sa
mère alors qui habiterait chez qui un
moment mon appartement est déjà prêt
donc tu peux venir d'accord d'habiter
chez elle à paris
elle était chez moi à montréal voilà ce
que c'est pas l'accent canadien
ça faisait beaucoup de chance annonce
annie paris les jeunes arrivés trop tard
le canada sera l'hiver déborde déjà lens
ça c'est vraiment du bien je me dis là
des gens qui nous regardent et amada
pardon moi je leur parle aux gens du
canada souvent je leur dis que leur
accent et l chier que c'est une image
ils m'en veulent pas quand même parce
qu'il sorte d'accord avec ça
m'embêterait s'écrie un accent québécois
chez une femme ouais je sais comment je
trouve ah ben on n'est pas d'accord là
dessus qu'il voudrait sortir seul moi je
sors pas je vraiment dans les boîtes
donc
c'est ça de régler voilà si tu fais ça
je lis je regarde je gardais film chez
un grand cinéphile donc voir au cinéma
et toi sortirai pas en fait je pense
qu'on resterait à regarder devant et
tous les deux en train de regarder tête
au coup de coude
j'ai vu une pub aujourd'hui pour un
soutien gorge que vachement bien
nous avons regardé
j'ai vu pour un site j'adore
et la bonne claque dit c'est ces gens
regardez moi dans les yeux
hélas cette fois ci la bonne femme dia
plus la télé dans la chambre je pense ou
pas sûrs y est vous votre nuit de noces
a forcément pays des mille collines
ouais bah oui c'est joli ça où il y
avait le cabaret de votre père ouais et
redites pas la même chose que vous avez
dit la dernière fois à propos de
l'auberge des mille collines
je dis pas que c'était un endroit assez
chaud non c'est pas chômé c'était chaud
le mariage ce matin
comment ce qu'elle est première dispute
à genève et giteau rien je vais pas bien
tapotage qui commettrait le premier le
péché d'adultère
donc c'est lui qui commettrait le
premier le péché d'adultère que j'étais
avec sonia non non d'accord ça va se
faire je suis pas je pense qu'ils vont
finir en son nom n'est pas demanderez le
divorce le premier en cas d'adultère en
cas d'adultère
ouais bah l'autre soupçonné la pension
alimentaire vous l'estimez à combien se
mit à tous les mois c'était faudrait
déjà qu'ils vendent pas mal de disques
va dépendre de ce que j'ai vu voilà
torné en tournée dans toute la france et
le 12 mai combas d'accord mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]